hi everybody my name is naya and i'm the
black female engineer
and i'm so happy to see you because
today i'm going to be talking about
the five key things i did that
allowed me to get overall three job
offers within a month of graduating
coding boot camp
one of those job offers happening three
hours after i had graduated which
to this day is just so mind-boggling to
me and so
when i look back there are some very key
things i did that may have been
different from my peers
that really allowed me to have such
amazing success so quickly number one
i tailored each of my portfolio projects
to something i would be proud talking
about
during an interview or to an employer or
putting on my resume
so encoding bootcamp
along with if you're self-teaching or
you're in college or anything like that
you will create projects for your
portfolio
you will create apps whether they be
web-based apps or mobile apps or a
mission
a mix between the two or anything like
that you'll create apps with the hope
of including them within your portfolio
or
for simply practice now what i did is
i really looked at
what things interest me the most and
things i could create
that i actually would be like look look
what i did
either because of the styling either
because of the features i included
within that app
i really made myself think
what is something that would really
differentiate myself
within that application process and so
what i ended up doing was creating three
main
web apps one was an ingredient
to recipe app called mints the second
was a budgeting app
and then the third was a social justice
app
however don't just think okay what
will impress x y and z company what will
impress or make my resume look all
you know cool and all that think about
the things you're
actually interested in so me i really
like to cook i like making new recipes
meal prepping all that
and so that's what drove the creation of
my first web app
the second the financial budgeting app
i come from finance and accounting that
is my background
and so knowing that and then me being in
my early 20s
i know that i can you know go off the
rules when it comes to
my spending habits and things like that
and so i created an app tailored
to that and then the third i'm very
passionate about social justice
and like to think of ways i can be of
help
whenever um i can and so create an
app to assist in that so i'm not saying
just
think about oh i think it'll be really
cool if you know
like no think about things you're really
interested in so
let's say you're really interested in
birds so there's actually a story that
was shared with us
during coding boot camp where somebody
was really interested in birds
they created kind of a shazam
type app for bird sounds so you hear
the sound of a bird and you could put up
your phone
and shazam it and that
would in turn provide you the type of
bird that
is making that sound and so like that's
so so interesting and so cool and so i'm
not saying
you know think about you know the stock
market or think about you know
economic no like think about things that
are interesting to you
and to create an app that really ties in
that interest
and build your features and the
styling and the all those
stuff on something that an intern would
be impressive to share with others
number two the next thing i did was i
started
applying to jobs two months
before i was set to even graduate from
the coding boot camp
so i
it is very important that
you listen to this do not apply
to your holy grail of a job do not apply
to your dream job at this time don't
apply don't be applying to you know
google twitter
you know all the jazz just
yet because when you're applying to jobs
in this period again
about two months before i graduate
coding boot camp or
before you graduate your self-teaching
schedule
college etc apply
to the jobs and positions that
you wouldn't really cry yourself to
sleep at night
for not getting the goal with
this is to really
allow for that practice and get in the
groove
of setting out resumes and in turn
interviewing so because the first jobs
you would have applied to are the ones
that
aren't your dream job now
ideally those are the jobs that would
contact you first for an interview
now you're interviewing with them treat
it as more of
a practice run so i'm not
saying you know go in there with your
loose
shirt and you're you know popping the
hoodie popping the collar like no
i'm not saying do any of that what i'm
saying though
is because this isn't a job
that you've been dreaming all your life
of having
now you can one approach the interviews
with a bit
more ease and with a more relaxed
persona and you get to iron up the kinks
that you didn't even know you
had so before going to an interview
yes you're going to practice questions
yes you're going to practice
the coding part portions of
the interviews and the tech challenges
and things like that but when you're in
there and when you're
talking about your projects and your
previous experience and
your five strengths and weaknesses
you're going to realize certain
kinks you have in your story whether it
be
that you really don't know your project
as well as you thought you did or you
really
can't really share with the person on
the other side of the table
the magnitude of a certain strength or
weakness or et cetera
because now you're really in that
hot seat now you're getting feedback
from that employer that your mama
couldn't give you that you know your
brother your
girlfriend like they couldn't give you
because one
they love you and two they're not
trained
unless you know they're hr or some ish
but
they're not trained to look out
for certain buzzwords or certain
body language or things like that
because they're not trained to do that
it's going to be the interviewer's
feedback that's really going to
create those moments of oh wow i did not
realize i even sound like that or even
you know talk like that or things like
that that is why i recommend applying to
jobs two months
before your graduation to allow for that
practice that way
when it is time where you are applying
to your google and
your twitter and your facebook when
you're applying to those jobs
you are now more relaxed knowing
really what your capabilities are what
your real strengths are in interviews
and what to look out for so
that is tip number two now tip
number three whenever you see a job
you're interested in go on linkedin if
you don't have a linkedin
create one please please please create
one
look on linkedin and see who
is employed or has been employed by that
same company
and try to get connected with them when
i say try to get connected i don't mean
just you know click the request button
and then go along your merry day no
that is not what i mean what i mean is
reach out to them first with a short
message blurb
attached to that request so something
like
hi my name is maya i am really
interested in this job and this position
and saw that
you were recently employed as this or
that is your current role i would love
to speak with you about
the insights you have from being
involved in this company your life
dislikes etc that is how you should
connect with them
include those blurbs sharing that you're
not just looking for you know a plus one
in your connection list you're looking
for actual true
insight and knowledge into the company
into the role into the position by doing
this you're a
lot more likely to one get
that request approved by that person
and two now you'll have
a connection in the job you
want does that make sense now
whenever you post something on linkedin
whenever you share x
y and z that person and the role you
want in the company you want
will see it and what they do with that
information that is up to them i'm not i
i don't know but that is putting
so much closer to that end goal of
getting employed
than not doing that and that actually
brings us to tip
four whenever you complete a
project build a new web app create
an article about something you've
learned post
it on linkedin please
please post it because now with this
new connection list of people who
actually
are in the roles and positions of jobs
you want to be in
now when you share hey i just did x y z
project i just created this app
they not only see that okay you're
actually
dedicated to this career switch but
they have the power to
say to xy recruiter or xy
manager like oh did this person apply
yeah i actually saw that
they did x y and z i think you know i'm
really interested in them i think you
should be too
and see where that takes you and not
only that
a lot of times i've been in situations
where the person
i have reached out to actually ends up
being my interviewer or part of the
interview process because it's not just
the hr team that's doing interviews
it's the recruiter and hr team but it's
also members of the direct
teams you would be working on because
it's not only important that the
hr is not
only oh and i did it again okay it's not
only important
that the hr and recruiting team likes
you
but it's important for your potential
manager for your potential
co-workers to like youtube because at
the end of the day once that hr hires
you you know in some companies like it's
wraps this dude's like
they're out but it's the managers and
the co-workers that
are sticking with that are stuck with
you
so you know i'm but i'm sure you're a
very lovely person you're a great
team member so don't um don't put any
negative connotation
around that but please after
you gain those linkedin connections and
really start uploading your progress
and your projects and the apps and
honestly
bonus points if you can actually also
upload
a walkthrough video of you using your
apps on linkedin as well because a lot
of times if you say oh just go
here and you'll see my app or if the app
isn't you know
isn't available for the public
and you just say oh i created this and
then period then it's like
well okay like i guess i'll take your
word for it but
it's really nice getting to actually see
what that walkthrough is like so
upload a walkthrough video with it as
well
and y'all tip number five
i really think this is really really
really
what allowed me to get the jobs i did
in the time i did and that is
think about your competitive advantage
when it comes to the job process and
lean into that
so what do i mean by this when i started
learning how to code that was in
june of 2020 i had just
graduated from college
with a degree in accounting finance but
that's
i had just graduated from college in
may of 2020 so just one month before
now when it comes to college recruiting
that a lot of times is a whole different
process
than recruiting as a full-on
professional um who's been
doing this for five years three years
ten years et cetera
when your college when you're recruiting
out of college
there are portals that you have access
to that other people don't
because there are because companies
are posting jobs solely wanting to
graduate
either a college graduate or someone who
is about
to graduate college so i say all of this
because i had already graduated college
however i still had access
to these portals and to the jobs
that were looking for college graduates
and people who were about
to graduate college actually the job i
ended up signing on was a job that
work looking for current college
students
which i no longer was but because i was
in that
one year threshold i still qualified
and i ended up getting that
type of role so my competitive advantage
was the fact that i had just graduated
from college and had
access to these portals now
my peers did not have access to these
portals
when you're graduate coding boot camp
now the jobs you are looking at
are the same jobs that your peers
are looking at do you see where i'm
going with this they're the same jobs
your peers are looking at
and they may end up being the same jobs
your peers are applying to
and when you're being interviewed you
may be
interviewed at you know two o'clock and
then your peers being interviewed at 2
30. so it is so essential to think about
spaces you occupy that your peers
don't so i don't want you to say like
okay wait but i'm 35 years old and i
you know graduated 15 years like i i
don't
what there's nothing for me there
no so you are transitioning into
software engineering
that's amazing one congrats two
where are you transitioning from for me
that was
that was accounting and finance i would
recommend
looking at accounting and financial
firms and seeing what tech related
jobs they are posting so okay you worked
at bank of america
look to see if bank of america is
posting roles for software engineers
you are now a software engineer about to
be a software engineer
and you have all this experience and
education related to
the financial field now can all your
other
classmates say the same likely not
so think about that think about where
your background is in
and really steer into that during your
job hunt process
now okay let's say you haven't had a job
and you know you're a working
professional so
you're not just graduating from college
etc now what do you do
if you remember i talked about the app
the person who was really interested in
birds built
that in itself could be a competitive
advantage so
you're really into birds now you have
created
three portfolio projects to really aid
the bird community
to really set yourself apart and because
of your bird passion and things like
that
apply to roles that would really
appreciate that now i don't know jack
squat about birds
so i really can to think of a company
maybe like the national wildlife
preserve
or the national association of bird
watching or like things like that
think about roles and companies
that would appreciate this passion of
yours and
apply to those because while other
people may be applying out of just
you know generic job hunt looking stuff
you're applying because you have this
deep passion that's been proven because
of your portfolio projects
and things like that and so again
this comes down to thinking about your
competitive advantage
and what sets you apart from
beth kathy tom chad all of them
over here where is the space that you
can occupy
that none of them can now
just a little asterisk over here
don't only apply to those rules i'm not
saying just
toss those other positions into the
trash and don't even bother with those
i'm not saying that still apply to the
roles that you see
pop up on linkedin the ones that you see
pop up
on you know google when you search
software engineering roles near me and
things like that still apply to those i
did
but focus less on those and i'd say
focus
at least 60 to the jobs that are more
your competitive advantage type of jobs
because
even though i still applied to jobs that
were popping up on linkedin popping up
on google
i applied to a total of i want to say
upwards 60 jobs in my job hunt process
but do you want to know which jobs i got
interviewed for
85 percent were the jobs that were in my
niche
so think about that so thank you so so
much for
joining me today i'll be talking next
about
the resume that got me my dream job
please let me know your thoughts on this
video
the tips and really any other questions
that you'd really like me to
go into my next videos because at the
end of the day
this is for you so i want to make sure
i'm being useful so thank you so much
for watching this and getting through
this with me
and i look forward to seeing you soon